my name is virginia abram i'm a senior
studying history and minoring in
journalism
and it is my pleasure to introduce
tonight's speaker
michael duran is a senior fellow at the
hudson institute
where he specializes in middle east
security issues
he received his ba from stanford
university
and his m.a and phd from princeton
university
duran served in the george w bush
administration
as a senior director in the national
security council
with responsibility for the entire
middle east except iraq
a former senior fellow at the brookings
institution
dr duran has taught at nyu princeton
and the university of central florida
he has written for numerous publications
including the wall street journal
the new york times the new york post
usa today and the los angeles times
he is the author of three books
including pan-arabism before nasser
egyptian power politics and the
palestine question
and ike's gamble america's rise to
dominance in the middle east
please join me in welcoming michael
duran
[Applause]
thank you virginia and thanks to all of
you for coming
thanks for to hillsdale for hosting this
it's the first time i've ever been to
hillsdale it's a great honor to be here
it's fabulous um to see an institution
like this um for me it's fabulous
because
i i'm a refugee as virginia
alluded uh i'm a refugee from
academia and
i left about 15 years ago my last
teaching position was at
princeton and when i
left princeton the the political
correctness
uh the progressivism was already
intolerable and um
i had this naive idea
back then that the pendulum was just
going to swing
because it had gotten so ridiculous i
thought 15 years ago that the pendulum
had to swing
but everything that i see and everything
that i hear from my friends is that no
actually the pendulum is not swinging it
just uh it just continues and all of the
major
institutions especially in the
humanities
and social sciences all of the middle
all the all of the major institutions
almost all of american academia is just
speaking with
one monotone voice
and so an institution like hillsdale
that has
something different to say and says it
uh
clearly and with conviction it punches
way above its weight it's a it's a
it's it's a fascinating thing and it's
just great to be here and be part of
this
um i thank you for having me so
what what i'm gonna do today is uh talk
to you
about uh uh trump and the middle east
or really the united states and the
middle east uh
but what i intend to do here is uh argue
uh that what donald trump is doing in
the middle east
makes an enormous amount of sense
it is coherent
intelligent and successful
and that is not something that you hear
very often
and i would like to go into some depth
here to explain to you why i think that
now if you if you uh been following the
news lately you know that uh
just recently the president had on the
south
lawn of the white house a signing
ceremony with
israel and the united arab emirates in
bahrain
where they where they assigned on to
what has been called the
abraham accords now if you followed the
press
on this if you read the new york times
then the interpretation that you heard
was that uh this is basically
the story of the emperor's new clothes
uh that donald trump was up there in the
in the white house lawn uh uh
thinking that he was wearing a resp
resplendent robes of a peacemaker
um when actually not that much was
was going on yes it wasn't a bad
thing that the uae and bahrain were
were making peace with israel but were
they really ever
at war with israel no
and you know this is really just kind of
a glitzy
formalization of a status quo that we're
all familiar with and oh by the way
donald trump didn't have anything to do
with it anyway it was really
benjamin netanyahu and
[Music]
mohammed bin zayed the united arab
emirates who made it happen
trump just played host to this
uh to this garden party um
well what i want to argue to you for you
today
is that indeed
the emperor's new clothes is a proper
lens
through which to view that event
but only with the roles reversed
trump really was wearing resplendent
robes of a peacemaker
and the people who were naked were the
critics
now if you've been following
trump's middle east policies and you've
been following what
the critics have been saying then you
know that at every stage
he has the critics have been saying that
what he's doing
is wrong-headed it's counterproductive
and it's going to lead to war and that's
you know from from
from moment one that was the case now
let me give you just a little example of
the
the the flavor of the analyses that
we've been hearing
uh uh in uh in uh
early or late 2017
then secretary of state
kerry was asked donald trump was a
president-elect
and he was asked what if
trump moves the embassy to jerusalem
what will happen and john kerry said
this is john kerry as secretary of state
he said you'd have an explosion
an absolute explosion in the region
not just in the west bank and perhaps
even in israel itself
but throughout the region so the whole
middle east is going to explode and it
goes on to suggest that maybe even the
peace agreements between
israel and egypt and jordan might fall
apart
as a result now that line of analysis
has pursued trump on everything he's
done
moving the embassy from jerusalem
recognizing the israeli sovereignty over
the golan heights
getting out of the jcpoa the iran or the
iran nuclear deal
reimposing sanctions on on iran killing
qasim suleimani the head of the
kurds force of the iranian revolutionary
guards
every time he's done something like this
we've been told
the prediction ahead of time has been
that uh
that it's going to lead to war uh trump
is alienating allies it's going to lead
to war it's counterproductive
uh and in the case of qasim suleimani
after he did it it was a mistake that's
also is going to lead to war
none of this has come true now you can
dismiss
you know or you can explain some of this
absolutely horrendous
prediction track record of prediction
as just partisan politics we live in a
very polarized moment
uh trump is a polarizing figure anything
he does is gonna is gonna
is going to be criticized and and and
it's absolutely true but the interesting
thing
i mean it's absolutely true that some of
this opposition can be just
put down to you know politics um
as politics is played but in in the case
of the middle east that's not completely
true
because the predictions that somebody
like john kerry is making
are also backed up but you just have to
trust me on this they are also
backed up by all of the experts on them
or a very large percentage of the uh of
the experts
who are putting their opinions forward
not simply for partisan political
reasons
they actually they actually believe what
they're saying but they're being proven
wrong
uh time and time again and so that's
what i want to dig into here
um a little bit um an interesting
question by the way i'm told that
students are going to ask me questions
afterwards so
uh i don't know if you've already got
your uh your questions ready
or or or if you're supposed to prepare
them while
while i'm talking so i'll um
i'll help you out if i don't get to it
ask me how is it that donald trump
nobody has ever suggested that donald
trump has a lot of patience
for intelligence briefings or even long
poly he's not interested in the the
minute detail
of uh a policy he has no
reservoirs of experience on the middle
east
how is it that donald trump is getting
it so right
and the experts are getting it so wrong
it's a fascinating question
i'm going to kind of answer it here but
i have a feeling that i'm going to run
out of time so you can ask me the
question and answer
i'd love to i'd love to answer it but i
have a lot of other stuff i have to
cover here
okay what i what i want to do what i
want to suggest to you is there are
there are two paradigms
for looking at the middle east um and
these are these are policy paradigms but
they're also intellectual
uh intellectual paradigms and for for
the sake of the discussion i'm going to
call it
um the obama paradigm and the trump
paradigm
but but but beware
beware that that is just a
simplification
that there are there are people
you know it's not just simply
republicans and democrats the obama
paradigm
is more prevalent among democrats than
it is among republicans but there are
republicans who see
the world through what i'm calling the
obama uh
the obama paradigm it's just sort of
there are two american lenses
for for seeing the middle east um uh
and i'll explain to you you know his
sort of historically where they come
from historically i mean just in the
last
um in the last uh 10 15 years
um are starting starting with the iraq
war
the when george w bush
went into iraq and the united states got
bogged down
they're developed among uh
the foreign policy elite a sort of deep
critique
of everything that bush had done
wrong and this was again primarily a
democratic critique
but it was there were also republicans
who shared it
and we have a document that sort of
codifies
uh in for all time the
critique of bush's uh of bush's policy
and that document is the baker hamilton
report just out of curiosity about the
students here anybody know what the
baker hamilton report is
just to raise your hand none of you do
okay the baker hamilton report was a
congressionally mandated
um study of what's gone wrong in iraq
so it's 2006 we're bogged down in iraq
things aren't going well
congress says to bush we you have to
have a
bipartisan study of how things have gone
badly
and so the the the baker hamilton report
is
is headed by lee hamilton of indiana
and james baker the former secretary of
state of george
h.w bush by the way everyone thought
that
that james baker was george
w bush's because he had worked for
bush's father that he was george w
bush's
ringer on the baker hamilton report that
he was there to do the bidding a bit of
of
of bush and to and to draft the report
in such a way
that would be helpful to to bush's
agenda
not true not true james baker
has the obama worldview the obama
paradigm
anyway uh the baker hamilton report by
the way was
penned the guy who actually wrote the
words on the page
by ben rhodes
he worked for lee hamilton ben rhodes
goes on to be
the deputy national security advisor for
strategic communications
of president obama he's a very
significant figure in the uh in the
obama white house part of obama's
inner circle so what the baker hamilton
report is is it's not simply the
critique
of bush from the foreign policy elite
it's also the blueprint of obama's
foreign policy
now the baker hamilton report has
it's it's worth looking at online it's a
little book
it's got hundreds of pages none of them
matter except
about the first five pages uh the rest
of it is all
window dressing um another another good
question i i won't go into what i mean
by that but
you might want to ask me about that one
of you uh enterprising students who
doesn't want to thank
just ask me that question because it's
kind of interesting but the the
all that matters in the baker hamilton
report are the are the five
major recommendations and those
are pulled out of iraq
pull the troops out of iraq just give up
on this failed war
plus up in afghanistan put more troops
into afghanistan
reach out to iran
reach out to syria so engage iran
against syria
and revitalize the arab-israeli peace
process
in particular the palestinian israeli
peace process
now in these in these uh five
recommendations
is the essence of the alternative
worldview or the the the obama worldview
about
um uh about the middle east
and the basic idea that the basic
perspective
is this the united states
drove its military into iraq
got bogged down and in doing so
it threatened syria and it threatened
iran
and at the same time by the way george w
bush is also
calling for a democracy promotion around
the world and that's also alienating
countries like
russia now the fact of the matter is
this is the perspective this is the
obama perspective this is not
i'm speaking now in the the perspective
of the baker hamilton report not the
perspective of mike
of of mike mike duran
in this world view iran
and syria and the united states have
shared interests
in iraq iraq is right next to iran and
why would it why would iran want to have
a
destabilized country on its borders
obviously it wants to stabilize iraq and
the united states could work with iran
to stabilize
iraq if it didn't have its military
there and
the military wasn't threatening iran
iran is afraid the united states wants
to carry out regime change against it
and so
there's this reservoir of shared
interests that the united states and
iran have but because of our
overly militaristic foreign policy we
have created a situation that doesn't
allow us
to benefit from the shared interest with
the iranians or
or or with the syrians
so if we just get out
and we signal to the iranians and the
syrians that we want to get out then
that will create
a space in which we can start to have
some creative diplomacy with them
and stabilize the region they won't the
iranians then won't be working and the
syrians won't be working
to kill americans as the iranians were
or
or to destabilize uh iraq at all the
israeli-palestinian conflict well the
bush
there's a there's a hidden critique of
bush there bush is too close to the
israelis and in particular to ariel
sharon who was the leader of israel
at the time and combined
and the israelis are too militaristic
so there's a the combination of you
the u.s militarized foreign policy in
iraq and the alliance with israel
is alienating muslims worldwide so we
need to demonstrate
to them to not just to the palestinians
but also to the muslims worldwide
that we are that we are conciliatory
and not aggressive and so we need to do
that that will also by the way
have uh um a good effect on syria which
remember we alienated
by putting our forces in uh um
into iraq so we're going to switch from
from military to diplomacy and we are
going to reach out
to these actors that we have been that
bush regards
as malignant actors that need to be
contained we're actually going to start
uh working with them while we revitalize
the arab israeli conflict
the the the the the bullet point about
putting troops in afghanistan well
that's about
al-qaeda that that 911
the bush justified the war in iraq
because of 9 11
but iraq had nothing to do with it the
real the real conflict is against al
qaeda
so what we need is narrow counter
terrorism
focused specifically at al qaeda and the
larger agenda that bush had in the
middle east we should uh we
we we should abandon uh
that is in that's the essence that is
the blueprint
of the obama foreign policy now obama
the the single most important decision
that president obama made
about the middle east he made
before he ever was elected president in
fact he made it
before he was even the the officially
the democratic
nominee uh before he ever talked to an
ally before he ever got an intelligence
briefing he made a key decision
and that kind of that kind of dictated
every move he made
thereafter and we have a record of this
the moment when he made this decision
he was the president this is in 2000 and
uh 2008 and he is the presumptive
uh uh nominee of the party
and he hasn't yet been officially uh
made officially the the nominee and he
goes on a
congressional delegation to iraq and he
meets there with david petraeus the
commander of our troops in
uh in iraq and he tells petraeus
if i'm elected president i'm going to
pull the troops out of iraq
and petraeus says it says to him
my best advice to you would be not to do
that
because if you do that iran will move in
and iran will take over iran will fill
the vacuum
as we as we leave and obama
says um yes i you know i'm look i can
see the map up there they're sitting in
uh
you know in in petraeus's office he's
got a map of iraq on the wall
and he says i can see the map i
understand that that's what's going to
happen but
you know we have to we we have problems
at home we have to worry about
uh we we cannot afford to be involved in
this war
uh anymore so
the decision is and this is in keeping
with the baker hamilton
report the decision is that that
what obama is assuming is that iran and
the united states
actually share a lot of interests
and if iran understands that in that the
united states is not going to be too
that is not going to topple it and
and that it doesn't intend to use the
military that it has in iraq against
iran
well then there's all kinds of
opportunities for um
for diplomacy between iran and and the
u.s and iran
will stabilize iraq in a way that will
that the united states can live with
comfortably
that is the key decision
that obama made because it was a
decision not
to contain iran presidents
prior to obama saw the united states
there's there's two competing world
views here they saw the united states as
the leader
of a coalition of states in the middle
east
whose goal the code the goal of the
coalition
was to contain uh malevolent actors
iran first first and foremost
obama basically gave up on kentucky now
he inherited
a huge number of policies and
let's say an american posture that is
going to work to contain iran in a lot
of ways
but you can't find a single decision
that obama ever made
to actually contain uh uh contain iran
and
every decision that he made moved in the
exact opposite
uh the exact opposite direction
now what he what he has in mind here
is the sort of two there's if you
imagine two different visions of the
middle east
one vision is the middle east is a
rectangular table
and on one side of the table is the
united states and its allies
yeah uh israel saudi arabia turkey
uh egypt jordan you know you know you
know all of them and on the other side
are the malevolent actors uh russia iran
syria hezbollah and so forth in that
view the job of the united states is to
elevate
the united states and its allies up over
the malevolent actors on the other side
that's the head leading leading the
coalition
view obama views the middle east as a
round table
and sitting at the table are america's
traditional allies but also
russia iran uh syria and so on
and all of these all of these people at
the table
are stakeholders in middle eastern order
and the united states is there to bring
the everyone around the table to
agreement
on key issues so the the what obama is
thinking is
i want to pull i want to pull out of
these wars these mistaken wars that
george w
bush started and i want to pull back
from the middle east the middle east
doesn't matter that much anymore
i want to pull back there's going to be
some vacuum there how are we going to
fill the vacuum we're going to fill the
vacuum
by rebalancing and that is rebalancing
between
america's allies and and america's
enemies and in fact
in an interview in the atlantic magazine
obama said
specifically with regard to saudi arabia
but it also applies to israel and to
turkey and
the other uh the other states the other
allies
that the saudis need to learn to share
the region with iran so
think about that because what he's
saying is
america's allies are the problem
america's allies are provoking iran
just like the united states is provoking
iran with its forces
in iraq so along with this baker
hamilton
view of the middle east what i'm calling
the obama view
is is a a reading of iran
that is very prevalent in america's
national security elite
which sees iran as basically a defensive
power
and a status quo power and one
one and a pragmatic power with which the
united states
can uh can can operate
now this is the context
in which you need to understand the
iran nuclear deal obama very cleverly
sold the nuclear deal
to the u.s public as a narrow
arms control agreement and whenever
anyone said
oh but what you're doing is actually
elevating iran up you're strengthening
iran against our allies
nonsense nonsense we're stopping them
from getting a bomb
so and this and this is just an arms
control agreement it has
nothing to do with anything else it's a
it's a blatant lie and i i
it's this week of all weeks it's very
easy to show you that it's a blatant lie
or
yeah let me be nicer to president obama
it's it's an it's a
it's a um you know it's a it's an uh uh
an act of of artful misdirection
the the the way i can prove that is that
uh
is that the conventional arms
embargo on iran is being lifted now
uh by the jcpoa this is why if you've
been following the news lately you see
president trump
has is is unilaterally imposing a
conventional arms
embargo so if this was a narrow arms
control agreement with respect to
nuclear weapons
how come lifting the conventional arms
embargo on iran is part of it and i
could go through lots of other aspects
of the
of the agreement both written and not
written uh
uh show you that this is this is part of
a larger conception
of reconfiguring the american position
in the region and the american
position vis-a-vis iran and it has
nothing to do with
with uh it's not primarily about nuclear
weapons and in fact it doesn't stop iran
from getting a nuclear bomb either
actually it actually creates a kind of
a a very clear pathway to a bomb for the
uh the iranians uh now
why did he do this basically what he did
is he parked obama came to an agreement
with the iranians
that would park the nuclear question off
to one side
for eight to ten years until you know
long after obama and
long after uh the next the the next the
term of the
the first term of the next president or
maybe even the second term of the next
president
and he parked it off to one side because
then he could affect
this change where the united states
becomes the power
holding the balance between the
different actors in the region rather
than leading a coalition
against iran he was getting the united
states out of the iran conflict
the problem is that all of america's
allies
and the american people don't like
iran's nuclear program this is a this is
a domestic political issue
so he could not affect this sort of
grand strategic change
if he didn't uh if he didn't park the
nuclear question
uh off to one side now the problem one
of the
there are many problems with this
conception as a
as i as i see it but one of the major
and most immediate
problems is that it it uh enraged
america's allies
because for their point of view
the u.s was just heading for the exits
in the region
and it was empowering the russians and
the iranians as it left
in 2015 right on the heels of the
of the completion of the jcpoa the iran
nuclear deal
the russians and the iranians put
together a military alliance i just
realized i don't have a clock
i looked up to look for the clock and
there is no clock
how long have i been talking about five
minutes right
matt how much longer do i have here 10
more minutes
okay i got 20 more minutes that's good
so
the uh the um
all that talk about minutes now i lost
my train of thought i was saying
something really interesting
oh the rest of the year thank you thank
you thank you thank you uh
so uh the russians and the iranians made
a military alliance
and uh and intervened in syria
on behalf of the assad regime the assad
regime being the closest ally
of iran uh and so the russians and the
iranians
moved in in order to prop up
the uh to prop up the um
uh uh the assad regime uh this was a
uh this was a move that was extremely uh
threatening to both israel and turkey
i'd love attentive students love to talk
about the turkey dimension of this but i
won't have time so remember that from
questions afterwards
the uh uh threatening to both
israel and turkey and obama's policy
uh basically not in so many words
told both of them the israelis and the
turks to sit down and shut up
and benjamin netanyahu did not do that
he came
to washington you'll recall and the
prime minister of israel and he gave
an address before both houses of
congress
in which he said that the nuclear deal
with iran
is a bad deal one that has
is actually defining a path to a bomb
for iran and at the same time there's a
certain
this is my words not has a certain
hidden codisl to the iran deal
which is recognizing iran
recognizing syria as an iranian sphere
of interest
uh and uh we we in the region
we have to be concerned about this rise
of iran iran has
is distributing militias in in four
arab countries now iraq syria lebanon
and yemen and then it's creating
militias on the ground and then
distributing to them
precision guided weaponry so this is
freaking out this is a political science
term it's it's freaking out
the the uh the allies in the region is
that they can't believe
that the united states is sort of
holding the ring
around syria and yemen
and and iraq and allowing iran to build
up
this this kind of this kind of power
okay
so that's the obama worldview
the trump world view is
starts from the same premise as obama
but it goes
down a very different path and the the
premise
is this that the united states
wants to pull back from the middle east
um
it does it it no longer wants to put
large numbers of troops uh on the ground
it wants to avoid military conflict
to to the extent possible
so just like president obama thought
this through in the
in and realized that there was going to
be a a vacuum president obama's answer
to what's what's going to fill the
vacuum
a concert system of all the stakeholders
in in in the region and trump returns to
the idea
of the united states leading a coalition
a coalition designed to to contain
uh uh to to contain iran
but like obama he also does not want to
have a
large uh u.s military footprint on the
ground
so trump obama wants a rebalancing it's
a rebalancing between america's allies
and america's enemies traditional
enemies traditional allies
traditional enemies trump says no no the
rebalancing has to go on
between the united states and its allies
so he's saying to saudi arabia and to
israel and to turkey as well
yes i am still your ally yes i will work
with you
to safeguard your your interests but you
have to do more right that is
that is the that is the space
into which the emiratis and the israelis
together
with the bahrainis have moved and that
is the
that is the genesis of the the uh
of the the peace agreement that we saw
on the the south lawn i'm going to say
more about that in a second but let me
say a few words about the palestinian
the palestinian question remember in the
old in the obama worldview
the uh uh we had to have an
uh we had to have a peace process on
uh an israeli-palestinian peace process
remember that that was part of the baker
hamilton report the congressionally
mandated report on what
on iraq so somehow in their mind
think about this a peace process on
israel is going to help us stabilize
iraq
how the party you just have to take
my word for uh my word for it i don't
have enough time to go into it deeply
here but you have to take my word for it
that
there are two different perspectives
just like on the
between the obama worldview and the
trump worldview there are two different
perspectives on iran
i actually forgot to fill that space in
there a little bit
the trump uh view of iran that iran is a
malevolent
power with hegemonic aspirations that is
in um inveterately hostile to the united
states and its allies
so that when you create a vacuum and
iran starts to move into it
it doesn't open up a space for diplomacy
and agreement with iran
iran will just pocket all of the
concessions that it gets
and then demand more from you because it
is always hostile to you
right so there so there are two
different visions of
iran there are also two different
visions of the arab-israeli conflict
the obama worldview says the
israeli-palestinian conflict is one of
great strategic significance
it also it is the the the cause of the
conflict also is
israeli policy not palestinian policies
and israeli policies and attitudes not
palestinian policies and attitudes
so but even beyond that
it is important for the united states
always to be seen to be working to make
arab-israeli peace because
this is such a symbolically
laden conflict in the islamic world
that the association of the united
states
with israel in the eyes of muslims is
damaging to the reputation
of the united states the united states
is tarnished
in the muslim world by its association
with israel
and so the way that the united states
has to
contain the reputational damage
is by engaging in a peace process with
israel this is deep in
uh the sort of the the the the
democratic uh the democratic mindset
that's why john kerry believes that if
we move our embassy to jerusalem
the region is going to explode
so donald trump's view which is correct
and i say that as a completely objective
observer and an expert on the middle
east
with a with a graduate degree from
princeton university
this is actually a relatively
minor geographic conflict between israel
and the palestinians
and what he has been doing while he's
been while he has been
containing iran and having this dialogue
with the allies about rebalancing roles
and
responsibilities within the alliance
he has also been whittling down the uh
the israeli-palestinian conflict and he
has been
basically bypassing the palestinians and
saying you will no longer have a veto
over everything that israel does with
the other with with with the other arab
states
the other arab states have been happy to
take this deal that
that that trump is offering uh
for for two reasons uh one
uh uh they they now see
you know that you know they they the
world has moved on
the the the latest generation um
uh of arab of arabs once you know once a
better future
they don't want to be stuck in the
paradigms of the past they want to move
forward they can see that israel
is a healthy vibrant democracy with a uh
with a with an innovative uh
technologically based economy
and so forth and they and they see
opportunities for themselves and they
would like to uh
they would like to enjoy those um
opportunities
but they also want to vector the united
states they can see that the united
states
under trump as under obama is sending
great
messages of great ambiguity about the
american role
in the middle east and about whether the
america america is even going to stick
around
in the in the middle east and so one way
to look at this is that this is a block
coming together to work with the united
states to contain iran
and to realize the potential of arab and
israeli partnership in doing so
but another way to see it is that this
is a block that's kind of developing
together
in the region in order to lobby
washington
about what its proper role in the in the
middle east is
um and when i started at the beginning i
told you that the the the the new york
times is saying well this is just
between israel and bahrain and
and the uae and the these are little
minor
minor players uh it's not really very
significant
hogwash the the bahrainis and the uae
would not be doing it if they didn't
have the tacit support of saudi arabia
which is the single most important
country in the uh
in the arab world this is really the way
you should really see this
this is the beginning of a normalization
process with saudi arabia
and with president trump told us in the
meeting on the white house lawn
five other states those are probably uh
those are probably kuwait oman
morocco qatar and
sudan which is quite shocking
actually so what we're looking at
is the end of the arab-israeli conflict
the palestinian
you know as distinct from the
palestinian-israeli conflict the
palestinian-israeli conflict
will move on i mean we'll live we'll
live on there's nothing to do about that
they'll they'll keep throwing that in
trump's face and saying well you haven't
solved the palestinian israeli economy
as if anyone can
right nobody can do that what he's done
is he's saying
yes i can't solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict so
i am going to i'm going to put a ring
around it i'm going to set it off to one
side like obama did with
with the iranian nuclear deal and i'm
going to go go about the business
of putting together a coalition with
israel and the uh
and the arab states it's practical it's
pragmatic
it's wise and it's very successful
now um let me just
i matt over here is making faces at me
and screaming and stomping his feet
so let me let me bring this to an end
but let me let me bring it to an end
with with another quote from
noted middle east expert
john kerry so
uh i'm going to go ahead and answer the
question
then i'm about to do damage to one of
the students here because i told you you
could ask this question
i'm going to give you a little bit of an
explanation i
i i can still i can still answer in
greater depth about
how is it that trump gets it so right
when he doesn't have any background in
the middle
in the middle east well
it's his instincts are right his his
instincts are
to look after the american interest to
look after the friends
uh uh uh of of uh uh of america he has
the same instinct that he doesn't want
to be taken advantage of you
hear that all the time by the friends
but it doesn't mean we don't have
friends but we have to rebalance those
so he listened to the friends it's as
simple as that it's not that he had
brilliant advisers next to him telling
him what to do he talked to benjamin
netanyahu he talked to
muhammad bin zayed in in
in in the uae he talks to mohammed bin
salman in saudi arabia and they tell him
and they were these guys were telling
obama
the same thing for years just obama
wasn't listening because he knew better
right now what's the proof that they
were talking
well in in 2008
the king of saudi arabia at the time
told america to the key is to cut off
the head of the snake meaning iran
iran is the problem iran iran iran and
then in 2015
i'm sorry 2016 benjamin netanyahu
the prime minister of israel gave a
speech at the united nations general
assembly
and he said for the first time in my
lifetime this is 2016 so obama's still
president
for the first time in my lifetime many
other states in the region recognize
that israel is not
their enemy he continued our common
enemies are iran
and isis our common goals
are security prosperity and peace
i believe that in the years ahead we
will work together to achieve these
goals
work together openly okay that's a
prediction that benjamin netanyahu made
everybody at the time dismissed it just
like they dismissed what trump is saying
as just so much verbiage from the crazy
right-wing
israeli prime minister now here's what
john kerry said
immediately after netanyahu said that
now kerry is still
secretary of state uh kerry kerry before
kerry made the the
the iran nuclear deal kerry devoted
at the a year the better part of two
years to trying to broker
israeli-palestinian peace you got
nothing
you got nothing all of that senior level
uh
leadership of you know all that time the
most precious thing you have as a senior
leader in the american government is
your time
all that time he devoted to this
conflict which has no strategic
i'm sorry no i got i i i engaged in
hyperbole which i occasionally do
let me be let me be more measured it's
very important students to be very
measured
in your in your judgments it has limited
strategic significance and he devoted it
was his
it was his number one priority and he
got nothing for it
and netanyahu is telling him in the in
the general assembly
there's another way john there's another
way
work to bring israel and the arab states
together and just forget about the
palestinian question for a while
kerry goes ballistic and in a public
statement
he says let me tell you if you can look
this up on the web because it's fun to
watch him he's
didactic and you know he's telling you
with all of his knowledge as secretary
of state
let me tell you a few things that i've
learned for sure in the last few years
this is in public he's making a
statement there will be
no separate peace between israel and the
arab world
i want to make that very clear to all of
you
and then just to make sure that you
understand that he's talking directly to
benjamin
netanyahu he says
i have heard israeli politicians saying
well the arab world is in a different
place now we just have to reach out to
them
and we can work some things with the
arab world and then we'll do a deal
and then and then after that we'll do a
deal with the palestinians
kerry says no no no
and no well that
belongs that's that belongs in the long
list
of uh of horrendously bad predictions
that john kerry has made about the
middle east i'm not
singling him john kerry out because as i
say
all of these predictions are backed up
by experts on the middle
east because they all have that same
view of the region
which i laid out to you
donald trump has a different view
and he is completely impervious to the
views
of the experts and it's a very good
thing because what's happening in the
middle east uh
in his in his tenure is very positive
for the people of the region
and for the united states thank you
thank you dr duran we now have some time
for q
a if you have a question please make
your way to the microphone
michael use the term traditional enemies
and traditional allies of the united
states
that very phraseology seems to be in
contrast to what the early founders
such as george washington and john
quincy adams articulated american
foreign policy
as resisting entangling and not
alliances so in this conversation you
mentioned
iran as this major opponent of america
and the middle east
and yet it's worth pointing out that
iran and the persian shia generally
speaking
have never committed a terror attack on
american soil the same is not true
about arab sunni muslims and yet so i
guess my
my question to you is you're a supporter
of the iraq war you played a significant
role in that policy decision can you
just
run through the logic that um that you
used to defend that war
or have you recanted some of your
earlier positions ah
interesting um so
uh you're right i did support the
the iraq war but i had nothing to do
with the decision making about it
um even when i was in the white house
i'm not trying to
to evade your question just in the
interest of accuracy
uh yes uh uh
i have uh um
i have regrets about the iraq war
and my support for it i i look now
um and i see that i had certain
assumptions about how
everything was going to go that where i
i made certain
john kerry style predictions that were
that turned out to be totally false
i i it never occurred to me
um for example i always regarded iran
as the primary enemy and i thought that
we would
uh i thought that we would use our
position
in iraq in order to contain iran
which i thought would be a good thing
and we never did that
we basically um we basically
opened up the we not this was never
george w bush's intention it was obama's
intention
uh uh it was uh uh it was the effect
of george bush's policy that we opened
the doors of iraq
to iranian influence so i look at all of
the
lives lost all of the treasure uh
wasted and i don't see the strategic
advantage
that i thought was gonna that was was
going to come
from this um as far as your larger
question is concerned about um
entanglements it's it's this is not
something i can i can only give it to
you this is this is a story of a much
larger discussion the beginning of a
much larger discussion
i'll just give you bullet points here
it's my strong belief that
our position in uh in the middle
east is absolutely crucial to defending
american freedom
um at home um and basically
you can read i wrote an article a couple
of weeks ago in tablet magazine called
china's emerging middle eastern kingdom
um and have a look at it because i lay
out the scenario there if we pick up
if we pull up stakes and just leave the
middle east
china is going to come in and take over
like
like that in in two seconds uh china
will take over
um and china will then dominate the
global energy
markets uh and they will use that
domination
to basically finland dies
all of um eurasia they'll take over the
middle east in two seconds and then
they'll use that
from that position they will detach
europe from the united states
and uh uh and then they will use that
position in the global uh
economy then uh uh to
undermine our own uh our own
institutions
have uh uh uh have a look at that
article but i
i i think that um trump
has trump is walking the line i think
very intelligently between
minimizing the military risk
um while maintaining the u.s position
which is crucial
in the in the struggle to contain china
hi i was wondering if you would be
willing to touch upon a bit what you
think the u.s relationship should be
with for example
the various kurdish factions within the
middle east consisting that in recent
years
the kurdish forces have been absolutely
essential to
with with helping u.s forces on the
ground in their war against
isis and whatnot and also in maintaining
some sort of balance against the assad
regime in syria
but at the same time they're also the
enemies of our allies turkey so i just
was wondering if
you'd be willing to comment on that
relationship i'd love to
that's again the beginning of a very
large conversation
but fortunately there's another article
of mine that i can direct you to
uh which uh i published about a week ago
with the hoover institution and their
online magazine called caravan just look
up duran that's my name
mr magoo uh uh and
um that's the beginning of the
discussion there
just again in a nutshell uh
when obama aligned with iran in the
region
he aligned with iran across the board
including in the
um in in the uh in the kurdish arena
uh the there's no uh you americans often
say kurds kurds curves we i like the
kurds i want kurdish autonomy
there's no such thing as kurds saying
kurd is like saying
is like saying arab the question is
which arabs you know and in particular
which
organizations so
what the united states did when it
aligned
with iran is it aligned with the pkk
which is the enemy of turkey wants to
bust up turkey into two
in in into two states now i go in
in the article i explain how we did this
and how we dressed it up and pretended
that we weren't doing that when we did
when we did we are
we are still aligned to this day with
the pkk
and that has done more than anything to
damage our relations
with um with with turkey
now there was another option the
the barzani faction in in the krg in the
iraqi kurdistan
is anti-pkk and it has good relations
with the turks
so if we had what we should have done we
came
we borrowed the pkk was the natural ally
of assad russia and iran
and we borrowed the the pkk
to defeat isis because it did not
threaten
iran and russia because we were
recognizing syria tacitly
as as an iranian russian sphere of
influence
the cost of that just like the the the
cost of the policy was to alienate the
israelis and the saudis
because we elevated iran the cost
in the in the northern syria was that we
alienated the turks because we aligned
with the pkk
so what i what i i think turkey is the
strategic prize and
turkey obama detached turk
obama tells a story about each ally
that focuses on their moral failings so
when they
when when when when netanyahu raised his
head above the parapet and said
don't align with iran obama said
you're oppressing the palestinians
when when saudi arabia made a peep
it was it was you
are you are a an uh an islamic extremist
despotism
you need to reform and democratize at
home
when the turks raise the peep it was
your your
your murdering kurds and you're
supported you're tacitly supporting isis
right that uh um none of these
is true each one takes a little sliver
of of reality and then blows it up into
a
you know into a uh into an indictment of
our
allies um the the in the case of the
um in the case of the turks the single
worst thing that obama did
uh uh in the middle east i think
actually was to detach
turkey from the american alliance system
everyone is understanding that these
days i'm an outlier by the way i'm the
only guy in washington
or one of the few in washington that
makes this argument i'm an outlier
on this but i'm right i'm objective and
remember that i have an advanced degree
from princeton
from princeton university so anyway
there's a much
larger discussion it's very interesting
but i i better stop there because i
could go on
okay i think we have time for one more
question
good evening i just wanted to know if we
continue with the trump approach which
you say is the correct approach what
does the middle east look like in say 20
years and does it open up an avenue to
solving the
israeli-palestine conflict um
the the simple answer is it it opens up
an avenue
uh it it it creates a um
better chance of reaching an
israeli-palestinian
deal than any than the other framework
the other the other framework
incentivized the palestinians always to
say no
if you go back from from oslo
to the uh to the i don't know if these
if these terms mean anything to you but
at each stage
we offered the every time the
palestinians said no we offered them
more
uh or we used our influence to to get
the israelis to offer them more
so there was what rabine was offering
the the
the the palestinians in the mid 90s
then there's what barack offered in 2000
then there are the clinton parameters
which clinton came out with after barack
after the second intifada started and
then there's ulmert's
offer in 2008.
and each time we put pressure on the
israelis
because remember we're defining the
problem as israel
not the palestinian intransigence it's
israel we put pressure on the israelis
to come up with more
and then as barack obama is leaving the
white house in 2009 you remember he
kicked the israelis with a u.n
resolution
that recognized the four june 67
boundaries as an international boundary
which they never were they were uh the
the armistice lines of 19 of 1949
were the were the these were the
ceasefire lines
that um that were behind which the
israelis at the the four june 67 lines
before the war in 67
were the armistice lines of 1949 these
are not international boundaries
obama was turning them into an
international boundary trump is erasing
that
so if you're the palestinians and you're
sitting there
the if you're abu mazen and you're
watching you
all i have to do is sit here like an
amoeba and say no no no it's not enough
to any offer that's made
and and the americans will come back and
offer me something better
so of course you're just going to
continue to sit there and say no i mean
to the extent that pilot that this kind
of negotiation is a rational
activity between actors who were trying
to come to a deal
now having said all that i don't believe
the palestinian leadership can make a
deal
so i'm not i i'm mike duran i'm not
going to hold my breath
until the palestinians come forward and
say yes
but if you ask the question as you did
then there's a much better chance in the
trump formula because the world is now
moving on
and the palestinians have been offered
something uh
that approximates what they've been
offered in the past it's not it's not as
good but it approximates and they can
negotiate for better if they
if they want and and the world is moving
on if they don't want to take it they
don't take it
as as trump says i'm okay either way
right that's a
that's a healthier place for america to
be because this
there's no reason why our policy in the
region
should be hamstrung by by the by the by
the palestinian question it makes no
sense
please join me in thanking dr duran